let's go to James from Southern
California James from Southern
California welcome to the program what
is on your mind today sir
thank you very much David are you able
to hear me okay I can hear you
beautifully
um I want to start by thanking you for
everything you do I really appreciate uh
all you've done over the years on your
program
um I uh I have a comment and I have a
question sure
one comment I want to make uh regarding
the people with the Maga mentality uh I
really want to encourage everyone to be
patient with these folks because we can
get through to them I've had a lot of
success and I think the approach I use
is very important in remembering that
they do live in fear to some extent they
have very much happen to us and them
mentality oh yeah and if you can
establish that you are one of them and
we are us they will listen to you and as
long as you don't tell them they're
wrong but simply give them information
but build from the bottom up remembering
they're they're ignorant like little
children
um and you need to use terms and
Concepts and once you have them on their
your side and they're agreeing with you
you can start correcting the
misinformation that's in their head and
help them kind of rebuild their view of
reality I don't disagree with that one
bit
it takes a lot of patience yes and I
really want to encourage people to go
out to friends family members who are
frustrating you and try to approach them
as they are a little child well here's
the thing James everything you're saying
is correct the important thing to
remember is that's like a retail
strategy person by person and it's
insanely time consuming doesn't mean we
don't do it but it is insanely time
consuming we also want to see is there
some wholesale approach that might
deprogram larger numbers of these people
and that's a tougher question to answer
it is indeed but I believe we need to
approach this from the Grassroots
because we all have a friend or family
member that we are probably avoiding
instead we need to help them right we
need to help our community and I think
it's a big part it's on us uh rather
than letting it happen we need to be
patient and take the time and yes it is
time consuming but it does work it can
be done I I have faith in that and I
just wanted to make that comment because
many of us are feeling a little hopeless
but don't give up on it you know take
that stand anyway I have a question for
you sure
um I was wondering what do you think the
uh odds are of Tucker Carlson ending up
on Newsmax
that's a good question you know I I have
I have no idea I don't think I have
anything substantive or objective that I
could say could Tucker Carlson end up on
Newsmax I know the CEO of Newsmax
interestingly enough he's kind of like a
fan of my work interestingly even though
our our political views are very very
different
um he is at heart a business person and
so without a doubt if I had to bet I
would bet that he's looking to see what
could happen maybe with Tucker Carlson
on Newsmax my instinct is that it would
be neither prestigious nor lucrative
enough for for Tucker Carlson
uh to join I think Tucker Carlson would
have more to gain from launching his own
thing from scratch but uh it's not
impossible it's not I don't know where
Tucker is going to end up
yeah I don't either I'm worried about
that I was just wondering about your
take on that well thank you so much
David I really appreciate everything you
do for us my pleasure James from
Southern California very very good to
hear from you why don't we go next to
Bert in New Jersey Bert in New Jersey
welcome to the David Pacman show
hey jumping right in again uh calling
you for another Wednesday we're
pretending to be on work calls so all
right
um I want to ask you um I think it was a
Rolling Stone magazine reported a couple
weeks ago that when Trump got arraigned
he had the option to do it over Zoom for
more Lago and not go into uh Manhattan I
don't know if you heard anything about
this whether that that's true because if
it is that's significant where you know
he complains about New York City
spending all this money and everything
all could have been avoided the circus
could have avoided had he done that I am
not aware that Trump was given the
opportunity to be arraigned via Zoom uh
let's see if I search for that Trump
arraignment via Zoom opportunity
um fact check did Trump refuse
arraignment over Zoom from Mar-A-Lago
um there was a tweet posted about that
what is the verdict
um unnamed sources only and no actual
verified evidence so at this point it is
at best an unverified claim so I mean
listen either way I've not seen anything
verified that Trump could have stayed at
Mar-A-Lago what I do know is that that
Court was not doing anything over Zoom
for a while now now whether they would
have made a special exception for Trump
maybe but Trump said he wanted the whole
Pomp and Circumstance he wanted to be
handcuffed he wanted a mug shot
supposedly because he thought it would
help him so I don't know if any of
that's true I can't imagine Trump would
have wanted to do it by Zoom
yeah interesting uh thing to follow just
in case that turns out to be true yeah
now one more question too heard you on
the Patrick fit David podcast yeah I
love that uh you know I thought it was
great it's so such a breath of fresh air
to hear
instead of just a typical cable news
propaganda you have two people with
conflicting ideologies like recognize
each other's logic right it's so
rewarding to hear yeah I mean I don't
know about sometimes there wasn't much
logic I have to tell you Bert but I know
what you're saying at least hearing the
rationale yeah yeah there were instances
where he was forced to kind of Nod his
head and go oh okay you know I I know I
have no rebuttal for that yeah those are
those are critical key moments
um question I have and I think all your
audience members is also wondering too
when are you gonna sit down and do round
two with Ben Shapiro because we would
love that we Ben Shapiro hasn't been on
I think for like 10 years we've invited
him multiple times he never responds and
you know he doesn't have any
responsibility to me he's he's way
bigger than I am and he may be just too
busy for me and that's totally fine but
we've invited him a bunch of times it's
up to him when we sit down again not up
to me I'm willing to do it anytime
awesome awesome day here all right
thanks Bert from Jersey uh all good
questions very important stuff and
different things going on